[موسيقى]
الحياه الاجتماعيه والدينيه قبل تاسيس
الدوله السعوديه الاولى يمكن ان اجزها لك
بما يلي
الدين الاسلامي موجود وهناك من يلتزم
بتطبيق الشرائع وهناك من لا يلتزم والصوره
التي ضخمها الباحث العربي ابن بشر بان
الحياه الاجتماعيه يسودها
حاله من الكفر والفقر والجهل والبدع
عباده بذلك المستوى
الاساس في نشوء الدوله السعوديه الاولى هو
حاجه المجتمع في نجد
والجزيره العربيه الى تحقيق حكم سياسي
مركزي يقوم على فرض الامن وخاصه امن قوافل
الحج والتجاره والسابله
[موسيقى]
وهذه المهمه التي
ركز عليها الامام محمد بن سعود ليست وليده
اللحظه انذاك بل اجداده من قبله كانوا
يقومون بهذه المهمه نعم سواء الامير مانع
الامريكي او ابنه
موسى او ابراهيم بن موسى
بن ربيعه حيث بينت وثيقه ايضا من كنوز
الارشيف العثماني ان الدوله العثمانيه
خاطبت حاكم الاحساء بتكريم عده اشخاص من
امراء نجد منهم الامير
ابراهيم بن موسى المريدي حاكم وامير
الدرعيه الذي كان يقوم انا ذاك بحفظ امن
قوافل الحج ورعايه افرادها وتسهيل مهمتهم
بالوصول الى الاماكن المقدسه
[موسيقى]